-Performing
"Dancin' in the Country"
from his self-titled
debut solo album,
please welcome Tyler Hubbard!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, what's up, baby?
Y'all ready to get your dance on
tonight?
♪ Them neon lights
look good on you ♪
♪ So good on you,
but we ain't got ♪
♪ No room to move,
no room to move ♪
♪ We need some space,
and I know a place ♪
♪ Outside of town where it
don't ever close down ♪
♪ No, we never close down ♪
♪ Yeah, we can two step,
put 'cha boots on, baby ♪
♪ We can do that,
girl, cut a little loose ♪
♪ You can move that,
move that, aw, yeah ♪
♪ I'll take you
dancin' in the country ♪
♪ Levis in them low beams ♪
♪ Spin you in some red dirt ♪
♪ Sweep you off of both feet ♪
♪ Out here where
the sun sets ♪
♪ Silverado backbeat ♪
♪ You'll never wanna go home
and never wanna not be ♪
♪ Dancin' in the country ♪
♪ We're dancin' in the country
Oh, yeah.
♪ Yeah, it goes left, right,
left ♪
♪ You makin' me wanna sway ♪
♪ Makin' me wanna play
some Alabama and Jackson ♪
♪ Got you round my neck,
makin' me wanna stay ♪
♪ Makin' me wanna lay ya down
here in the pasture ♪
♪ Yeah, we can two step,
put 'cha boots on, baby ♪
♪ We can do that,
girl, cut a little loose ♪
♪ You can move that,
move that, aw, yeah ♪
♪ I'll take you
dancin' in the country ♪
♪ Levis in them low beams ♪
♪ Spin you in some red dirt ♪
♪ Sweep you off of both feet ♪
♪ Out here where the sun sets,
Silverado backbeat ♪
♪ She never wanna go home
and never wanna not be ♪
♪ Dancin' in the country ♪
♪ We're dancin'
in the country ♪
Ah, play it for a moment.
Let's go!
♪♪
How we feeling tonight, y'all?
♪ I know you feel that heat,
watermelon summer ♪
♪ Get them Luccheses
stompin' like the thunder ♪
♪ We can two step,
put 'cha boots on, baby ♪
♪ We can do that,
girl, cut a little loose ♪
♪ You can move that,
move that, aw, yeah ♪
♪ I'll take you dancin'
in the country ♪
♪ Levis in them low beams ♪
♪ Spin you in some red dirt ♪
♪ Sweep you off of both feet ♪
♪ Out here where the sun sets,
Silverado backbeat ♪
♪ She never wanna go home
and never wanna not be ♪
♪ Dancin' in the country ♪
-♪ Don't stop, don't stop ♪
-♪ Yeah, we're dancin'
in the country ♪
-♪ Don't stop, don't stop ♪
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-♪ We're dancin'
in the country ♪
-♪ Don't stop, don't stop ♪
-Come on.
♪ We're dancing in the country ♪
-♪ Don't stop, don't stop ♪
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Thank y'all so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Tyler Hubbard.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]